I want to welcome you all to the 2023
Castle lectures which are the signature
lectures for the epne program we had a
long pause before because of Kobe but
we're very pleased to finally be able to
be back here organizing these events in
person my name is Anna De Lao and I am
the director of the apne program
and before introducing our speaker today
Ben Weisner I want to tell you a little
bit about these Castle lectures
in 1988 John castle made a generous gift
to Yale to establish the lecture series
he did so in honor of his ancestor
Reverend James pierpoint
he was a harbor trained Congressional
Minister who founded the Collegiate
School of Connecticut in 1701.
soon after that school of Connecticut
was renamed after its benefactor Yale
we are grateful to Mr castle and his
family to the contribution of the
Twitter University broadly and to the
epne program in particular
the castle lectures aim to promote
awareness of the ethical challenges and
complexities of our society and they are
also meant to Foster robust dialogue
about the moral foundations of society
and government our speaker today is Ben
Weisner he's the director of the
American civil liberties Union's speech
privacy and Technology project in more
than two decades at the ACLU Ben has
litigated many significant cases at the
intersection of Human Rights and
National Security
including challenges to the surveillance
practices government security sorry
government watch list targeted killings
and torture since 2013 he has been the
Principal legal advisor to NSA
whistleblower Edward Snowden
Ben is a graduate of Harvard College and
New York University's School of Law
his lecture series are entitled Above
the Law or be needed how National
Security Law supports accountability and
weakened democracy
this lecture series are going to be a
divided in two parts so this is a
two-day event
today's lecture has a title anatomy of a
national security lawsuit tomorrow we're
gonna meet again at the same time 4 pm
to hear the second part of the lecture
which is entitled the case against
National Security
just a few words about the format of
these lectures we're gonna let Ben
present for about 45-50 minutes and then
we're going to have plenty of time for
questions so I'm going to ask you to
please hold your questions towards the
end even though I know this is going to
be a terrific and thought-provoking
lecture so please welcome me in joining
Ben and Ben the floor is yours thank you
thank you
thank you for that introduction Anna and
thank you all for being here this
afternoon
I'm honored to be invited to offer these
lectures in what is my hometown
one of the Privileges of growing up in a
community like this one is that you have
access to a world of expertise outside
your own family
when I was a 17 year old high school
senior nervous a little headstrong about
heading off to Harvard in the fall
I asked the political theorist Ian
Shapiro whether I should take the
year-long introduction to economics ec10
which at that time was taught by the
renowned conservative Economist Martin
feldstein
you could he responded and I will not
attempt a South African accent
or I could teach it to you in one
sentence
this was thrilling to hear
what's the sentence I asked his response
Imagine The World is Flat
at the time this sounded like a cryptic
koan
only later did I appreciate it as a glib
dismissal of the premise that human
behavior is best understood as a series
of rational cost-benefit analyzes
uh it's genuinely hard for me to Fathom
that I am older now than Ian Shapiro was
at the time of that Exchange
and that Harvard's canonical Act 10 is
now taught by one of my college Drinking
Buddies
no less boggling is that it now Falls to
me and my cohort to play zen master and
to perplex and Enlighten the youth so
here goes
if a bright and idealistic college
graduate on her way to law school were
to ask me today whether she should take
a course in National Security Law I
would be tempted to channel Ian Shapiro
and offer to teach it to her in a single
sentence something like
the time bomb is always ticking or maybe
we neither confirm nor deny what you see
in plain sight or better still
heads we win
tails you lose
national security law has not achieved
the status in law schools that
macroeconomics occupies in our colleges
and universities but it's on the March
in the two decades since the 9 11
attacks it's moved from the fringes of
law school curricula to a privileged
front and center position
new courses have proliferated new
journals have launched leading law
schools have announced prestigious
fellowships Think Tank collaborations
and all manner of Grace that the academy
can bestow
as a lawyer who spent the better part of
the last two decades litigating or
rather attempting to litigate National
Security Law cases I've observed these
developments with a mix of bewilderment
and annoyance
to be sure many of the questions and
controversies that fall within the
rubric of National Security Law are
vital ones that deserve significant
attention and careful scrutiny but when
confronted with those questions in
recent years courts in the United States
have almost uniformly refused to Grapple
with them instead deeming them
non-justiciable
did military officials violate the
constitution When They seized a U.S
citizen on U.S soil held him for years
in communicato and solitary confinement
and subjected him to beatings sensory
deprivation and for strugging
we don't know
because federal courts in South Carolina
and Virginia declined to answer on the
ground that Congress had not created a
specific cause of action for alleged
enemy combatants claiming abuse in
military custody
are there any legal constraints on the
government's authority to carry out
targeted killings of U.S citizen
terrorism suspects Far From Any
recognizable Battlefield
but otherwise can the government carry
out the extrajudicial killing of one of
its own citizens without even telling
him what conduct might subject him to
execution
we don't know
because the federal court in the
District of Columbia dismissed a lawsuit
on the ground that it falls to the
political branches rather than the
Judiciary to decide whether and when U.S
citizens may be killed overseas
does the federal law that authorizes the
mass acquisition of U.S citizens
International Telephone and email
Communications without individualized
judicial warrants violate the
Constitution's Fourth Amendment
we don't know
because the U.S Supreme Court said that
the plaintiffs who brought the challenge
could not show that their own
Communications had been swept up and
they therefore lacked standing to bring
a lawsuit
can a foreign citizen who was kidnapped
by the CIA in the case of mistaken
identity and imprisoned and abused in a
foreign dungeon claim any remedy under
U.S law
we don't know
because courts in Virginia accepted the
cia's argument that any litigation of
the claims would reveal State secrets
and damage National Security and just
last month
can the National Security Agency
intercept and copy all of Americans
International Communications including
emails web browsing content search
engine queries by installing
surveillance devices on the internet's
backbone and then search that massive
database without any Court approval we
don't know because in February the
Supreme Court refused to review a lower
Court ruling dismissing that case on
secrecy grounds warrantless surveillance
of American citizens kidnapping and
torture at home and abroad extrajudicial
kill lists
non-justiciable non-justiciable
non-justiciable
these outcomes deprive litigants of
remedies
but of Greater significance by failing
to say what the law is they deprive the
nation of a definitive adjudication
allow abuses to continue unchecked and
leave the door open for future
misconduct
even in those rare instances
in which courts have rejected these most
extreme outcomes most notably when the
Supreme Court repudiated the bush
administration's crude attempt to
overrule the Magna Carta in Guantanamo
the Court's rulings have often been more
symbol than substance
a court claiming Authority rather than
exercising it
the government may have lost three
Landmark Guantanamo cases but more than
20 years into the Guantanamo era the
Supreme Court still has not told us
whether indefinite detention without
trial there is lawful
all of this litigation without any
substantive outcomes
generates a kind of fog of law that
conceals what I believe to be the real
organizing principle of National
Security Law impunity for senior
officials
this regime is robust and malleable and
has proven Adept across decades at
identifying new hosts it will not be
dislodged anytime soon the more modest
goal of this polemic is to contribute to
a process of diminishing its
respectability
it makes perfect sense that the high
Priests of this order those senior
officials who float between top
positions in the intelligence community
and defense Contracting would seek to
imbue their project with the gravity and
solemnity of an existential struggle
and would view challenges to their Noble
efforts as attempts to tie their hands
what during what they insist on defining
as wartime
there's no good reason why the rest of
society least of all the academy should
consent to that definition or
participate in that myth making
the intelligence Community uses the term
indoctrination
to describe the process of being sworn
into the secret world of security
clearance
National Security Law likewise
seeks to indoctrinate us into a
profoundly anti-democratic way of
thinking about governance
National Security Law is organized
around the systematic exclusion of the
public from vital decisions about
government policy
it insists that the separate branches of
government that were designed to provide
a check on Executive abuses must instead
defer to the purported expertise of the
executive wrongdoers themselves
indeed National Security Law is
predicated on Democratic fragility
insofar as its Central claim that we
need an exceptional set of rules to
address putatively exceptional threats
invariably implies in Wendell Berry's
words that a democracy such as ours can
work only in the most favorable
circumstances
it's more than a little ironic that a
Rogues gallery of National Security
Elites has pulled off a Nifty recent
Rebrand by embracing the banner of
democracy after devoting their careers
to weakening its checks and balances
in tomorrow's lecture
I'll dig a little deeper into why I
believe National Security Law is at best
incoherent
and at worse a carefully cultivated
deception
today I want to take you on a journey
deep down the rabbit hole of one
relatively obscure national security
case
but before I do that I hope you'll
indulge a brief Admiral Stockdale moment
who am I what am I doing here this is my
test to see who in the room is 50 or
older very few
as is probably queer by now I don't
quite fit the profile of past lectures
in this series I've not spent my career
reading and writing about the issues
that I'm here to talk about but rather
being battered around by them in a
hostile Arena this was not by Design
I didn't set out to be a National
Security lawyer
mine was the last generation to graduate
law school before the 9 11 attacks and
thus before a national security law
became enshrined as a prominent fixture
our graduation week class Gala our
so-called Last Chance dance took place
at windows on the world Atop The World
Trade Center
on an exceptionally foggy night in May
of 2000.
among the many things we couldn't see
that night was how our wives and careers
would be shaped by the unthinkable
events that would unfold there a year
later
I've often thought about the cooks
Waiters
and cleaners who served us
and whether any of them might have died
in that room one year later
in August of 2001 a month before the day
that ended the end of History I joined
the ACLU as a staff attorney
Lionel training Lionel trilling said of
the Spanish Civil War everyone knew that
it was one of the decisive events of our
epic everyone said so at the time it was
being fought and everyone was right
this fairly well captures the sense of
dread and anticipation that we all
experienced in September of 2001. even
before Wars of choice were launched
prisoners were brutalized and our
national discourse devolved into the
conceptual and moral absurdity of a war
on terror
the two decades of my ACLU career have
tracked the two decades of this forever
War
from Washington DC courtrooms to
Guantanamo Bay Cuba
to the ancient capital of Yemen and most
unexpectedly to Moscow
but much of that time has been spent at
my desk reading and writing legal briefs
trying without success to persuade
courts to rule on the legality of
executive actions undertaken in the name
of National Security
there are National Security lawsuits
that produce lofty judicial
pronouncements and fill law school case
books there are others that make
headlines even if they don't make law
the case I'm going to talk about today
is none of those
it certainly is not among the more
important cases that I lost
I've chosen it because I think it
epitomizes the pathologies of National
Security litigation and offers a flavor
of the style of argument that the
government employs and courts routinely
accept in these cases
the lawsuit concerned a request under
the Freedom of Information Act for a few
dozen pages of documents in particular a
request at the Department of Defense and
the Central Intelligence Agency for
unredacted transcripts of a handful of
combatant status review tribunal
proceedings at Guantanamo Bay
if you don't know what that sentence
meant I congratulate you if you do hello
old friend we'll catch up after the
lecture
before I get to the case
I should set the stage and I apologize
to those of you for whom this is
remedial
the particular quasi-legal proceedings
at the center of this dispute represent
the convergence of two of the more
disgraceful policy decisions made by the
Bush Administration after 9 11. the
attempt to create a legal no man's land
in Guantanamo
and the creation of an archipelago of
secret cia-run torture prisons around
the world
the Bush Administration opened the
prison camp in Guantanamo Bay in January
2002. the plan of course was to locate
the prison outside the jurisdiction of
our federal courts to create an island
outside the law so that men and boys
could be
imprisoned without legal recourse and
interrogated without legal restraint
the prisoners were prohibited from
contacting lawyers and lawyers were
prohibited from visiting the prison
when human rights lawyers found a
workaround by locating family members of
the prisoners and initiating habeas
corpus proceedings in federal courts the
government insisted that the suits be
dismissed under rostational grounds with
no adjudication of whether the prisoners
had been lawfully captured and detained
with the government's argument to be the
same one federal judge asked in a
hearing in 2003 if the claims were that
the government was engaging in Acts of
torture
or even extrajudicial execution
yes at the Department of Justice there
would be no jurisdiction to consider
those claims either
in hindsight it seems clear that the
government would have been better off
inviting judicial review rather than
fighting it
as I mentioned earlier two decades later
and after a trio of cases in which the
Supreme Court repudiated the
government's efforts to evade any
judicial review the court has still not
answered the fundamental question
whether indefinite military military
detention at Guantanamo was or is
lawful
in other words the court dramatically
clawed back a power
that it has steadfastly designed and
declined to exercise
demonstrating a greater willingness
to defend its own prerogatives and to
interfere with executive abuses
in 2004 in the first of those three
cases the Supreme Court in rasulvi Bush
held that because the United States
exercised complete Sovereign control
over the Guantanamo Naval Base the
prisoners there could file habeas corpus
petitions in U.S federal courts about a
month after the Russell decision the
Department of Defense established the
compatant the combatant status review
tribunals or csit csrts as they are more
commonly called
these were ad hoc administrative bodies
charged with determining whether the
prisoners had been properly classified
as enemy combatants
depending on your perspective
CRTs were either quote the most generous
set of procedural protections ever
afforded aliens detained by this country
as enemy combatants as chief justice
Roberts would later write
or a potemkin proceeding designed to
offer an illusion of legal process and
thereby Stave off full-blown
intervention by federal courts
the csrts were composed of a panel of
three Military Officers and an officer
known as the recorder
who served in the prosecutorial role
the prisoners had no legal
representation
that tribunal could rely on secret
evidence and invariably did
and on evidence obtained through
coercive interrogation
if the csrt determined that the prisoner
was properly classified as an enemy
combatant which was the outcome in all
but 38 of the 558 hearings conducted
between July of 2004 and March of 2005.
that prisoner could be held at
Guantanamo indefinitely subject only to
an annual review before an
administrative review board
meanwhile
even as the Department of Defense was
insisting that Guantanamo held the worst
of the worst
Hardin terrorists who would in the words
of the nation's topped uniform military
officer chew through a Hydraulics cable
to bring a plane down
the Bush Administration had set up a
separate detention and interrogation
regime for a smaller number of prisoners
whom the CIA deemed high-value detainees
or hvds these were the so-called black
sites
the aptly named dungeons where the U.S
committed the gravest of all human
rights abuses forced disappearance
incommunicado detention brutal torture
even homicide
it was in these prisons that CIA
interrogators employed the techniques
that were purportedly authorized by the
notorious Department of Justice torture
memos including slamming prisoners into
walls depriving them of sleep for
prolonged periods chaining them into
stress positions placing them in a
confinement box with insects and
waterboarding
in September of 2006 the cia's remaining
high-value detainees were upgraded from
Secret CIA detention to indefinite
military detention and transferred from
black sites to Guantanamo
shortly after their transfer the 14
former CIA prisoners went through the
csrt process
and transcripts of those hearings were
released those transcripts were
incomplete virtually all references to
the prisoner's interrogation and
conditions of confinement had been
scrubbed from the released versions
for example during the March 14 2006
csrt hearing for Abid al-rahim anashiri
Mr nashiri stated that he had been
tortured in CIA custody
when a tribunal member asked him to
describe the methods that had been used
the release transcript recorded the
following
redacted
what else do I want to say
they were doing so many things what else
did they did redacted
after that another method of torture
began redacted
they used to ask me questions and the
investigator after that used to laugh
and I used to answer the answer that I
knew and if I didn't replay what I heard
he used to
redacted
all of that has been scene setting for
tonight's Main Event American civil
liberties Union versus Department of
Defense and Central Intelligence Agency
the ACLU submitted a Freedom of
Information Act request on April 20th
2007 seeking complete and unredacted
records of these csrt proceedings and we
followed that request with a lawsuit to
enforce it we knew better than to be
optimistic
but it seemed to us that the
government's basis for classifying these
transcripts was exceptionally weak
it would get even weaker as the
litigation progressed
first we weren't asking for official
government records describing the
torture program we simply wanted
transcripts that recorded the prisoners
experiences in their own words
unlike the notorious torture memos the
legal opinions drafted by the department
of Justice's office of legal counsel
that purported to authorize the brutal
techniques these prisoners were
subjected to these transcripts didn't
constitute official government policy on
the contrary they were the abbreviated
first-hand accounts of some of our most
reviled adversaries accounts that were
therefore easily dismissable and had in
fact been routinely dismissed as Lies by
senior officials
second
by the time this lawsuit reached the
courts the cia's torture program was no
secret
detailed accounts of the cia's black
sites and the brutality that occurred
there had been published and widely
disseminated during the course of the
litigation and particularly after
President Obama took office many
official records of abuse including the
torture memos were Declassified and
released
by any reasonable metric
the release of these transcripts should
have cost the government very little
that was not The cia's View
throughout the litigation
the CIA insisted that the redacted
portions of the transcripts must retain
their top secret designation
meaning they're always reasonably could
be expected to cause exceptionally grave
damage to National Security
because they included information about
the agency's intelligence sources and
methods
before we take a deeper dive into some
of the absurdities of the government's
argument I want to linger for a moment
on that core claim
the release of a few dozen pages of
hearing transcripts in which prisoners
describe their treatment in CIA custody
would endanger the nation
those of us who work in this area have
become so newer to this casual threat
inflation that we rarely pause to
consider what the government is asking
us to believe in this case that the
release of these 40 or so Pages would
have any impact on the security of a
global hyperpower much less and
exceptionally grave one
such an assertion should strike any
reasonable Observer as fundamentally odd
and the government offered some very odd
arguments in its defense
the first of those arguments was that
the government had the authority to
classify these transcripts in the first
place
by what law or logic we wondered could
the government classify the prisoner's
own words and memories derived from
their own observations and experiences
the government's authority to detain a
prisoner had never been understood to
Encompass the authority to classify any
and all utterances made by that prisoner
and the legal requirement that
classified National Security information
be owned by produce buyer for or be
under the control of the United States
government had never before been
extended to human beings under the
government's control
put even more bluntly
the CIA was arguing that it can subject
an individual to enhance interrogation
techniques
and then by virtue of that individual's
involuntary exposure to those techniques
alone enforce a permanent gag on his
communication
in a sworn declaration submitted to the
court a CIA associate information
officer stated that the 14 high-value
detainees included in plaintiff's
request have been exposed to
intelligence activities sources and
methods of information
specifically quoting the intelligence
activities to which the high value
detainees were exposed include the
capture detention confinement and
interrogation of detainees
that is they were exposed as it were
to themselves
what's more the cia's ability to conceal
this information was predicated entirely
on the government's physical custody of
the detainees in other words the
argument presumed that they would not be
released by this Logic the ACLU argued
the CIA could mistakenly detain and
coercively interrogate an entirely
innocent person something that in fact
happened many times
but if that person were exposed to
classified interrogation techniques
permitting him to describe his ordeal
would cause exceptionally grave harm to
National Security so his release would
be impossible
of course if the government were correct
that the detainees exposure to
classified intelligence sources and
methods Justified and indefinite gag on
their communication
then surely it would follow that whoever
disclosed those methods to terrorism
suspects had violated criminal statutes
prohibiting the transmission of
intelligent secrets to anyone
unauthorized to receive them that is to
say at the very moment that hooded CIA
interrogators were pouring water down
the throat of college Sheikh Mohammed
they were engaged in an unauthorized
leak of top secret information to an
avowed enemy of the United States no
less
that's obviously silly
the CIA interrogators and their bosses
should be prosecuted for torture not
leaking
but is it any sillier than the
government's argument here
and that was not even the strangest of
the arguments that the government made
the government had repeatedly
characterized the detainees torture
allegations as false
Secretary of Defense Rumsfeld for
example responded to a question about
torture at Guantanamo with ridicule
the detainees were doing exactly what
they were trained trained to tell people
tell them you're tortured tell them it's
terrible tell them this tell them that
that's what they do
even if we were to accept the argument
that the detainee's true accounts of
their own detention and interrogation
might include sensitive details
how could false accusations disclose
Secrets how could the government deny
and classify the same allegations
easily
as it turns out and with no discernible
embarrassment
according to the CIA sworn declaration
even false allegations about the
classified details of the program must
be treated as classified information the
CIA did not purport to explain how an
allegation could simultaneously be false
and be about the classified details of
the program an assertion that defies
ordinary logic
the Declaration then offered a
hypothetical
if the government were to redact only
true allegations regarding locations of
CIA detention facilities then the true
locations of these facilities
could be revealed by making multiple
allegations as the location through a
simple process of elimination
that doesn't strike me as very simple
was the CIA suggesting that publication
of it attaine's false assertion that he
was detained in say Afghanistan could
alert a canny Observer that the true
location was Morocco through some kind
of terrorist decoder ring
or was the government imagining a
scenario in which an expert manipulator
game the system by Falling falsely
naming every nation in the world except
one
the CIA did not elaborate
while the ACLU and the government were
trading sharply worded reefs President
Obama took office
and in one of his first executive orders
he categorically banned the
interrogation techniques that the CIA
insisted were classified sources and
methods of intelligence gathering this
should have resolved the litigation
How could a band technique a technique
that the CIA by law could not use again
remain a classifiable source and method
even assuming that the torture
techniques were at one point legitimate
and lawful methods of intelligence
gathering no amount of disclosure about
their past use could reveal details
about current intelligence sources and
methods that might be properly protected
by the CIA
in a new sworn declaration the CIA
acknowledged that the interrogation
techniques at issue had been prohibited
by law but it argued even if the
enhanced interrogation techniques are
never used again the United States will
continue to be involved in questioning
terrorists under legally approved
guidelines the information in these
documents would provide future
terrorists with a guidebook on how to
evade such questioning
if you're wondering exactly how
knowledge about band interrogation
techniques would Aid future captives in
resisting new and different techniques
you're not alone
the CIA made no effort to explain that
more disorienting was that the CIA
continued to press arguments in court
that directly contradicted with the
president their putative boss had said
in public
President Obama had repudiated the cia's
brutal interrogation techniques and
stated that they did not Advance our war
encounter terrorism efforts they
undermined them
but the government continued to argue in
our litigation that those techniques had
quote provided the U.S government with
one of the most useful tools in
combating terrorist threats to National
Security the CIA told the court that the
now banned techniques had quote led to
the disruption of a plot to fly a plane
into the tallest building in Los Angeles
and a plot to hijack passenger planes to
fly into Heathrow Airport
even though those claims had been
repeatedly debunked and were provably
false
the bush White House had itself
confirmed that the Los Angeles plot was
disrupted before the cia's detention and
interrogation program even began
and the British government dismissed the
cia's claim about the Heathrow plot as
completely and utterly wrong in a 2010
op-ed Boris Johnson wrote that the cia's
torture of prisoners had yielded no
information of value to the British
and that if former President Bush
traveled to the UK he might face arrest
for the crime of water boarding
prisoners and would never see Texas
again
to my knowledge President Bush and vice
president Cheney have gone nowhere near
Europe since leaving office
there was yet another dispositive reason
why withholding these transcripts was
legally impermissible
by the time the courts were considering
the case the government had Declassified
numerous documents that formally
acknowledged and described in detail the
interrogation techniques and conditions
of confinement at issue in the
litigation I've already mentioned the
notorious torture memos with President
Obama Declassified in April of 2009
these contained concrete and startling
operational details including the angle
of the gurney and the temperature of the
water used in waterboarding the
protocols for stress positions and sleep
deprivation deprivation and the
appalling admission
that one prisoner had been deprived of
sleep for 180 hours more than a week
a few months later the Obama
Administration also Declassified large
portions of a CIA Inspector General
report from 2004. that report described
multiple instances in which CIA
interrogators exceeded the authority
purportedly granted by the torture memos
including incidents in which al-nashiri
was threatened with a semi-automatic
handgun and a power drill
and college Nick Muhammad was warned by
interrogators that his children would be
killed if there were another terrorist
attack in the U.S
in contrast to the transcripts at issue
in our litigation which simply recorded
the detainees accounts of torture these
were official government records this
presented a new twist
the government had for decades argued
successfully that publication of mere
allegations about classified activities
could not compel the disclosure of
official government documents here
apparently for the first time
it argued that publication of official
government documents about classified
activities could not compel the
disclosure of mere allegations
hence we win
tails you lose
so to review
the transcripts contain descriptions of
the detainee's own experiences not any
official government account the details
of their interrogations had been
Declassified and made public in numerous
ways the president had banned the
techniques that were being withheld as
classified sources of methods and
despite all of that the CIA
still swore and Department of Justice
still argued that the release of these
transcripts would cause exceptional
engrave damage to the security of the
United States
by this point I doubt anyone is in
suspense about what happened next
the federal district court in Washington
DC had little difficulty sweeping our
arguments aside in a cursory order
it upheld the government's suppression
of the transcripts without even
conducting in-camera review to examine
them in other words it deemed the cia's
affidavits so credible that it declined
even to look at the transcripts before
awarding summary judgment to the
government
we appealed and the court of appeals for
the District of Columbia circuit held
oral arguments in September of 2010.
the Appellate panel included
conservative icons Lawrence Silberman
and David centell who made no effort to
hide their disdain for the lawsuit
they began by asking me why the ACLU
even wanted the transcripts if the
interrogation details had been released
elsewhere what was the point of our
request as judge Silberman put it the
argument is not very convincing that
says they should let us have this
because we already have it if we have a
non-sequitur contest you get to enter
that one
I responded that Under The Binding law
of their circuit the ACLU would be
entitled to the documents only if the
information the CIA claimed as sources
and methods had been released elsewhere
so any non-sequitur resulted from their
precedence not my illogic in any event I
argued under the foia it was not my
burden to explain why I wanted the
documents it was the government's burden
to justify their withholding
wait a minute said Justice Silverman
if this information is already in the
public record how do you even have
standing to sue forward under the foia
how is there even a case or controversy
this was another new one and really the
definition of a catch-22
to overcome the government's claimed
exemptions we were required to argue
that virtually identical information had
already been disclosed but if we argue
already been disclosed we would have no
standing to sue heads we win
tails you lose
judge Silverman's next line of
questioning threw me for a loop
did you ever see the movie Saving
Private Ryan he asked me
I've seen it your honor do you remember
the scene on Omaha Beach when German
soldiers were trying to surrender to GIS
but they were shot
I remembered the scene
if there had been a foia at that time
and the shootings had been recorded and
someone had requested the videos would
the government have had to release them
in Wartime
and here you have to admire the Casual
equation of wartime Normandy in the
spring of 1944 with wartime Washington
and that fraught and perilous Autumn of
2010. I responded it's our view that the
government cannot use a crime as the
basis for a cover-up
a contrary rule would create a perverse
incentive I argue the worse the
government's conduct the more exempt it
would be from disclosure this was the
opposite of what Congress intended when
it enacted the foia
I'm cherry picking some of my better
lines in this retelling but I should
acknowledge here that the court somewhat
statistically posts audio recordings of
oral arguments on its website and the
recording of this one paints a different
picture
the judges are relaxed almost bored
enjoying some occasional sport at my
expense I'm testy and can't hide my
annoyance we all know how it's going to
end
in an opinion issued on January 18 2011
the court unanimously affirmed summary
judgment for the government on the basis
of the cia's insistence that release of
the unredacted transcripts would damage
the security of the United States it did
so as had the district court without
even taking a few minutes to glance at
the disputed documents to see if the CIA
was lying about them
I've spent more time than I should have
on this particular and ultimately minor
case because I think it's possible to
distill from it the core tenets of
National Security Law and practice
the government wins
almost nonsensical arguments that would
insult the intelligence of a junior high
school debater you are prohibited from
speaking about these things that never
happened are put forth in somber tones
that the government demands that judges
defer to the expertise of the very
officials who Stand Accused of grave
misconduct
that demand is accompanied by wildly
inflated claims of harm that will result
if the court were instead to do its job
and finally the ostensible subject of
the dispute in this case transparency
versus secrecy is a contrived proxy for
what's actually at stake accountability
versus impunity
it should be obvious that the cia's
concern was not harmed to the nation but
harm to the CIA
the audience they had in mind was not
terrorists who might learn to evade
their interrogation techniques but the
American people who might be appalled by
them
the lesson of Abu grave was fresh images
of torture could produce a dramatically
different public reaction than written
descriptions
this explains the decision of senior Cia
leaders to destroy video evidence of
torture in Black sites the agency was
willing to risk potential liability for
obstruction of justice to avoid the more
probable Fallout that would occur if the
horrific videos were seen and
disseminated
might the public react strongly to the
emotional first-hand accounts of human
suffering contained in these redacted
transcripts
the CIA didn't want to take the chance
and it didn't have to
we would later learn a more significant
reason for the suppression of the
transcripts they contained compelling
evidence that the cia's torture regime
had been ineffective
and of course this was precisely why we
wanted these documents President Obama
had banned torture by executive order
but there was nothing to bind a future
president intend on reinstating intent
on reinstating it
meanwhile all of our lawsuits on behalf
of torture victims had been dismissed on
just disability grounds with no ruling
on the legality of the practices
and while President Obama had
disappointed us with his insistence that
a nation could look forward without
looking backwards we clung to the hope
that we could generate enough public
backlash to reinvigorate demands for
accountability at a minimum we hope to
assemble a comprehensive public record
there might be a value to investigators
in another place or time
I made the claim a minute ago that in
National Security litigation disputes
over secrecy operate as a proxy for
disputes over accountability I want to
illustrate more directly what I mean by
that
simply put in 2023 as we stand here very
little is secret about the cia's torture
program
but as a consequence of legal secrecy
doctrines every single lawsuit filed by
a torture victim since 9 11 has ended
without any adjudication of the law or
facts
in layman's terms no court that was
faced with a torture lawsuit ever
addressed the core question of whether
the victim's rights were violated
this includes the case of masri maybe
the most most well-known victim of the
cia's so-called extraordinary
extraordinary rendition program
in a notorious case of mistaken identity
El masri a German citizen was abducted
by Macedonian security officers while
visiting that country detained
incommunicado for weeks handed over to a
CIA Renditions team then stripped beaten
drugged via anal suppository diapered
chained to the floor of a plane and
transported to a secret CIA prison in
Afghanistan where he was detained in
abusive conditions for several months
senior U.S officials realized very
quickly that they had kidnapped an
innocent person
because he was a European citizen he
couldn't be dropped in Guantanamo to be
sorted out later so the CIA worked with
German intelligence to devise a plan
that would return him to Germany without
leaving obvious U.S fingerprints
al-masri was warned not to reveal his
experiences to the media or to local
German officials
then he was flown to Albania driven
blindfolded to a remote location and
left on the side of the road whereby
pre-arrangement he was picked up by
Albanian officers and put on a plane
home
this poorly scripted attempt to avoid
International Scandal flopped badly
on his return to Germany El masri
promptly contacted an attorney who
reported his story to the German police
public prosecutors initiated a formal
investigation that would later result in
arrest warrants for 13 suspected CIA
agents other European investigations
surfaced every damning detail of this
ugly episode
Macedonia was ordered by a European
Court to pay compensation to El masri I
won't offer a full anatomy of the aclu's
lawsuit that followed but you heard the
thumbnail version in my introduction our
suit against CIA officials and
contractors was dismissed at the outset
on the basis of an affidavit submitted
by who else the CIA director
who insisted that any litigation of
omasri's claims would disclose State
secrets and Gravely damage the nation's
security as we would later argue in an
unsuccessful Supreme Court petition the
al-masri case now stands for the
proposition that the government can
engage in torture to Claret a state
secret and by virtue of that designation
alone avoid any accountability for
conduct that has long been unlawful in
all circumstances
what's so unsettling about the secrecy
claims in this case is that al-masri was
not locked away in a black site or
Guantanamo he was free and available to
testify and we were prepared to litigate
his claims on public evidence in fact he
was sitting in the courtroom in Richmond
Virginia when Department of Justice
argued to the panel of appellate judges
that the entire subject matter of his
lawsuit was a state secret
I am not a state secret El masri would
later write in an op-ed piece in the Los
Angeles Times
as we'll discuss in more detail tomorrow
the government prevails in these cases
by insisting on a distinction between
what the entire world knows and with the
government itself is prepared to
acknowledge
in almasri's case that meant that his
own testimony
as well as all of the evidence on Earth
by investigators all of the witnesses
lab tests public records even the
judgments of foreign courts amounted to
zero so long as the CIA refused to make
a formal confession
this gives the executive branch complete
control over its own liability
even for the most serious crimes
there are a lot of words to describe
what's going on here
but I would submit that secrecy isn't a
particularly apt one
in June of 2016 more than five years
after the court of appeals upheld the
cia's suppression of the Guantanamo
transcripts the government quietly
released nearly complete versions in
response to a new ACLU foil lawsuit
by that time it was clear if there had
been any lingering doubt that the Obama
administration had absolutely no
interest in pursuing further
accountability for the torture
conspiracy
the unredacted transcripts make for
harrowing reading
they pulled my hands up and cuffed them
recounts Majid Khan so I won't be able
to kneel down and get rest for three
days
and when they took my clothes off and
took me to the bathroom and dipped me in
full ice in ice water tub and they
hanged me back again and this time they
would throw cold water and every few
hours and right next to me they would
turn on a fan days passed like this
three straight days
they shackle me completely even my head
recalls Abu zabeta I can't do anything
like this and they put one cloth in my
mouth and they put water water
last point before I die they stand the
bed and I tell him if you want to kill
me kill me
but it turned out that brutality wasn't
all that the CIA had hoped to conceal
several prisoners testified that they
had made false confessions and concocted
fake terrorist plots under torture to
appease their interrogators Abu zubaida
requested numerous times that the CIA
produced for the tribunal an email he
had sent to Islamic scholars after 9 11
asking them to clarify whether killing
innocent civilians was permissible
suggesting not only that he wasn't
involved but that he hadn't approved
and he testified that a CIA officer had
acknowledged that he wasn't even a
member of Al Qaeda and said to him sorry
we made a big mistake
this is what the CIA had fought so hard
to conceal under the banner of sources
and methods
the dirtiest secret was that the torture
prisons were not just sadistic they were
gratuitous
the story has one more quota
even as civil and criminal liability
efforts were being extinguished in the
U.S investigations proceeded overseas
including in Poland
where Abu zabeta had been held in a CIA
black site in 2002 and 2003.
in 2010 zubeda's American lawyers filed
a criminal complaint in Poland asking
prosecutors there to investigate whether
any polish Nationals were involved in
his harsh treatment
polish prosecutors reached out to the
U.S for information but were rebuffed on
National Security grounds so they closed
their investigation
but in 2015 the European court for human
rights took up the case and concluded
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt based on
voluminous evidence
the two Beta had in fact been held and
tortured at a CIA prison in Poland and
that Poland had failed to investigate
the matter adequately polish prosecutors
again sought information from the U.S
and they were again rebuffed
the prosecutors then told zubaida's
lawyers they were free to submit any
evidence that might Aid the
investigation and zubaida's lawyers
serve discovery requests on two CIA
psychologists who had worked in the
cia's black sites
the CIA moved to block these efforts
invoking the state Secrets privilege
while it was true CIA director Mike
Pompeo conceded in a sworn affidavit
that many details of the cia's enhanced
interrogation program had now been
Declassified
the CIA had never formally confirmed
that it had operated a prison in Poland
this dispute led to what has to have
been one of the more bizarre Supreme
Court cases in recent memory
did the CIA had run a black site in
Poland again was no secret after leaving
office the president of Poland at the
time had publicly confirmed that the CIA
had set up the Pres the prison with his
knowledge
and what has to be considered the
ultimate demonstration of the shrizand
effect the Supreme Court heard arguments
and published 80 pages of opinions all
devoted to the question whether Poland's
cooperation with the CIA
was a legitimate state secret
in the end seven of the nine justices
said that it was
as Ian Shapiro might say Imagine The
World is Flat
the court accepted the argument that
formal confirmation of Poland's role
might complicate the cia's future
efforts to enter into clandestine
Partnerships with foreign intelligence
services
this isn't illogical
it's just Limitless
it means that if the CIA makes sure to
involve a foreign partner it can always
invoke State secrets to foreclose
accountability
during the litigation the U.S government
proposed an alternative Way Forward
perhaps instead of deposing the CIA
psychologists Abu zabeta could write a
document from his cell in Guantanamo
describing his own Recollections this
caught my attention
was the government suggesting as a
resolution to this case exactly what it
had fought for years to prevent in my
not quite
the government reserved the right to
conduct a Security review of zubata's
manuscript
as Justice Gorsuch wrote in a surprising
descent
this was little more than an offer to
let zubetta say whatever the government
chooses to allow him to say
there comes a point Justice Gorsuch
wrote where we should not be ignorant as
judges of what we know to be true as
Citizens
for the majority of the Supreme Court
and for the U.S legal system as a whole
that time has not yet arrived
thank you for listening I hope to see
some of you tomorrow
and I would be glad to answer questions
I should warn you the answer to every
question is that's in tomorrow's lecture
foreign
[Applause]
thank you so much ben for really that a
fascinating and thought-provoking talk
we're going to use the microphone
because we are recording this lecture so
if you want to post a question please
raise your hand and I'll bring the
microphone to you
you mentioned that the ace
of the things you try to do is build
public backlash
um how did you go about doing that
especially
when uh support for the terrorists may
not have been very high
so it's a good question so when you
bring litigation that you expect is not
going to succeed in the court of law
you do so with the awareness that the
court of public opinion might be the
actual venue that you're litigating in
so the first thing that you need to do
of course is explain to the plaintiffs
in these cases
that we're not likely to Prevail so they
don't get re-traumatized through the
process but but part of it also is
of strategic litigation is choosing
plaintiffs right we brought a case on
behalf of Khalid al-masri who was an
innocent victim
we didn't bring that same case on behalf
of college Sheikh Mohammed who was
subjected to more brutal techniques for
precisely the reason you identify
if the question before the public is
what rights should terrorists have the
answer will usually not be a good one
but if you can present an error if you
can show what happens when due process
is deprived when you do punishment
before trial
then you can make people ask a different
question right are we willing to have a
system like this operating in our name
when we know that there might be dozens
or hundreds of people who were swept up
inadvertently because of the deprivation
of legal process
I I think there was there was some
success I don't want to be Pollyanna
sure obviously my talk was the opposite
of that right
we completely failed in court
there are some who have written books
David Cole at Georgetown Jack Goldsmith
at Harvard who argued that all of this
failed litigation in fact succeeded in a
way in turning the public against these
activities eventually getting Congress
activated making it politically
impossible for the CIA in the future
ever to agree to do something like this
again that may or may not be right we
don't know it's two ways of looking at
the same body of evidence that was
certainly the intent the intent was to
use litigation as a public demonstration
of what happens when you abandon the
rule of law
so I'm sure you're going to answer this
in tomorrow's lecture like you said but
in our discussion of Poland the the
thing I was thinking of was in 2023 what
does constitute a legitimate state
secret
in other words what do I consider to be
a legitimate secret
uh I mean are you asking if I think that
there are legitimate State Secrets yeah
okay so I do actually I think um there
are some who would take the position
that
um there is no such thing as a
legitimate government secret I think the
category isn't large
um uh Daniel Ellsberg recently gave an
interview to the New York Times in which
he said that he thinks maybe half of one
percent of what's classified should
still be classified but examples of what
is properly classified certainly the
identities of our agents or informants
overseas the disclosure of which would
lead to their deaths
we shouldn't be publishing troop
movement in advance if a newspaper found
out about the bin Laden raid the night
before it wouldn't be responsible to
publish the article before it happened
large group movements can't happen in
secret anymore there's no there's not
going to be another Normandy but still
that's legitimate and there may
certainly
there may still be some Secrets related
to nuclear proliferation not many I
think the real obstacle to proliferation
now is material and not information most
people have the knowledge but I think
those would be things that are
legitimate State secrets and I want to
make another point and I will get into
this more tomorrow
something might be a legitimate secret
but we don't have to treat that
assertion as absolute
in U.S law once a court accepts the
government's assertion that something is
secret say the U.S
relationship with Poland
um that's the end of the inquiry
but what a court really ought to do is
say what's at stake in this litigation
what are the countervailing principles
that are at stake here a torture
victim's right to have his case heard
the systems need to have a resolution of
an important legal question and balance
those interests whereas we don't have
any proportionality analysis we don't
have any balancing in the US legal
system once a secrecy claim is accepted
as legitimate that's it it basically
extinguishes the case that we're talking
about so that would be another
way that I would respond to that
question yes so I guess just to clarify
you're saying that these are not
necessarily enumerated like there's no
list of what constitutes
your legitimate state secret in 2000
that's that's exactly right and in fact
more I'll say more than that so so
if the government is invoking the state
Secrets privilege
the category that the law uses is
National Defense information the
definition of that is so broad that it
refers to almost anything relating to
the foreign policy of the United States
uh if it's given its plain meeting it's
clearly an unconstitutional law
courts generally equate it with
classified information but no there's
not anywhere you can find an enumerated
list of categories I mean there there
are some statutes that deal specifically
with say signals intelligence and they
would tell you with a little bit more
specificity but in general the state
Secrets privilege is a judicially
created Doctrine there isn't even a
statute that establishes it the courts
just said we're going to apply this
common law evidentiary privilege to give
the government the ability to shut down
these cases
so uh thank you for it first obviously
thank you for coming to to give this
lecture and the lecture tomorrow
um but I I think so so given so after
after listening to this uh for around an
hour now it's it's really depressing
right
um and so I guess for you like like
after Decades of doing this work
um do you ever find yourself wondering
if there are other venues other avenues
to be addressing these
uh in particular these particular cases
beyond the court of public opinion
beyond the judicial system especially if
we look at how entrenched the judicial
system and the political legislative
bodies have been over the past
a long time
yeah I mean so there are there are
courts and other jurisdictions so we
have helped present these cases to
courts and other countries
um uh paradoxically there were a case
that I didn't talk about tonight
involved five citizens some citizens of
the United Kingdom some citizens of
Sweden who were victims of the cia's
rendition program their lawsuit was
dismissed in the United States on state
secrecy grounds on the ground that the
CIA couldn't confirm or deny its
relationship with foreign partners and
the courts in those other countries gave
remedies to the same people so they
actually paid damages for their minor
roles in these Renditions so
um so if you're talking about a legal
system
there are courts in other places I also
think part of this is bearing witness
right uh General Pinochet in Chile did
not expect that he was going to be
arrested in London and spend his
Twilight years
fighting against accusations of what he
had done decades earlier so you know I
mentioned that bush and chain any don't
go to Europe right now so part of this
is shrinking the world for those people
it's one form of accountability
I I do think
public opinion is vital
because it creates the climate in which
the next president will decide whether
or not to try
something like this
um uh but I I you know I
and I I was deliberate this was a record
of failure right not my failure the
failure of the system
to give an answer to some of these most
fundamental questions and the question
I'm going to ask more pointedly tomorrow
is why are we putting this body of law
on a pedestal when it treats these vital
questions in these ways
thank you
um so the fact that the court isn't
answering these questions how much of
that do you think is the fact that
they're sort of delaying the requirement
that they come up with a satisfactory
answer because they they can't think of
one or because they already have an
answer and they just don't want to have
to justify it
I I well
um
the way that I've heard judges talk
about this
um and again I'll get into this tomorrow
in some more detail I actually will
is that when a senior leader of the
intelligence Community says to a judge
in my expert determination
if you take these steps it's going to
have X Y and Z effect on our national
security two things are happening first
of all the judge does doubt his own
judgment doesn't necessarily want to be
the one to make that decision in the
face of that claim the second what's
been communicated to that judge is that
if anything bad happens it's going to be
on you and all fingers are going to be
pointed at you so it's a political
comment as well and
um and the theatricality of some of the
ways in which these secrecy claims are
made with an executive branch security
officer coming into the judge's Chambers
with a briefcase handcuffed to his wrist
to deliver the classified Affidavit of
the CIA director there aren't a lot of
circumstances in which judges are going
to say you know that's nonsense there
are some
um
where we just passed the 50th
anniversary of the Pentagon papers case
where
the Nixon Administration Almost
Persuaded a federal judge to enjoin
publication on the basis of the
government's assertion that there would
be grave damage to National Security the
judge said later he was expecting to
enjoy it he kept saying to the
government where's the evidence that
something bad is going to happen and the
government wasn't able to produce
anything
um
more than a decade later the government
lawyer who was arguing this case said
hey I stood before The Supreme Court and
said the publication of these documents
were going to lead to grave damage I've
never seen a scintilla of evidence of
damage from their publication I've never
even seen anybody claim that there was
damage from their publication so again
my argument is that the judges need to
be considering the executive branch
claims in the context of that history of
deception but it's it's not easy the
much easier thing to do if you're a
judge is to kick it up to the next level
right there may be something else going
on as well if you're the Supreme Court
here which is that
um
it's a little odd to have an agency like
the CIA in a democracy
um that is we send agents out into the
world basically to break the law
and they don't want to then be dragged
into a U.S courtroom to have what they
did adjudicated after they were sent out
to do these things and so we come up
with ways of describing that like
secrecy but it's not secrecy it's really
just you know are trying to put some
scaffolding on a decision that we've
made that these people are going to
operate outside the law and it wouldn't
be fair to subject them to it and again
I don't think
that's irrational
um I just think it's terrifying right
because it has no limiting principle
um so for a class I was reading about
um Haitian refugees who were kept in the
Guantanamo prison camp and I know there
were some recent sort of unconfirmed I
think last year reports that the Biden
Administration was looking at keeping
migrants in
um in in Guantanamo in that area and I
was just wondering whether there are
sort of legal Avenues to preventing
um sort of the the detaining of these
types of of whether it's refugees or
political Prisoners has a legal system
sort of evolved in any way to prevent I
I'm I'm not an expert on the refugee
side of things but you should know that
actually law students and faculty here
at Yale 1990s brought successful
challenges on behalf of the Haitian
refugees who were held there then
against the Clinton Administration and
did create legal Pathways for those
people to be released from Guantanamo
and admitted into the United States and
so
um that's quite a distinct
um sort of category of law
as far as the remaining you know sort of
so-called war on terror detainees at
Guantanamo I think the best thing that
can be said about it is that
it's been a very very long time since
anyone has been brought to Guantanamo so
I think
the political class on legal class have
more or less decided they're just going
to let this problem age out they're just
going to let the people who are there
you know at an Incredible cost both in
dollars and moral Authority
um just grow old and die there the few
that are left
um and you know part of what's made it
so difficult to find homes even for the
ones who the U.S says should be released
is that Congress passed a law saying
that no one who's been in Guantanamo
could ever be admitted into the United
States
so we accepted zero
and now we're telling all the other
countries in the world if you don't like
Guantanamo you've got to take these
people
but we've taken none of them
so you know that has obviously made it
incredibly complicated to get 800 people
who are held there released and then and
then
um you know the last thing I'll say is
that of course
we still are holding the alleged
perpetrators of 9 11. out of Guantanamo
and their trial hasn't started
22 years after the attack
why hasn't the trial started come
tomorrow
I'm not kidding
I'll be here okay yeah
thank you
so then just um I guess a a quick
question
uh given that you mentioned being a
so that it made me
think about the processes of Truth and
Reconciliation in Latin America and the
end of dictatorships in the southern con
and part of that process in some in some
ways was a a product of also internal
splits within the military and younger
cohorts being tired of being accused for
the crimes of the Elder cohorts I I
wonder if you see something like that
happening within the CIA or or do you
still see that as a monolithic
closed agency I don't know enough to
answer that I mean there were plenty of
people in the military who objected I
mean that's why we know about Abu garib
that was a military whistleblower there
were many uniformed officers who came
forward and said
we can't torture prisoners because our
people become prisoners so uh and you
had people who were still in the
military who said that and then you had
hundreds of officers who had retired
from the military who in brief after
brief to the Supreme Court
um you know made this argument so
um so there definitely were dissenters
the only evidence we have from the CIA
side
is you know I mentioned there's a 2004
CIA Inspector General report
um the reason why there's an inspector
general report is that there were people
CIA people who were on site saying this
is crazy illegal and Reporting it to
their Inspector General so but but all
you know except for brief moments all of
those internal investigations stay under
wraps
um they you know that that 2004 report
wasn't Declassified until
2010 and still redacted and you see how
the CIA fought against the release of
the Senate's investigation even hacking
Senate investigators to try to figure
out what they knew about the cia's
torture program so
um so I I don't know I think again I
think
um
what's
I mean anyone who has been in a
leadership position at the CIA knows how
legally tenuous their position is the
minute that you let law inside
as soon as you let external law inside
so much of what they do becomes
problematic
um you know the the former CIA general
counsel his Memoir was called company
man
right and I think that better describes
the attitude of people there
thank you
so at a panel I watched shortly after
the Snowden Revelations with Chris
segolian actually and oh can you hear me
okay I hear you fine okay and uh and
Mike Hayden Mike Hayden said
uh he sort of acknowledged there was a
failure of transparency and that there
was a need for what he called
translucence
which I take to be some measured form of
transparency
and I later read uh Edgar's book where
he also sort of claimed that there had
been improvements in transparency post
Snowden Tim at timicker's book exactly
yeah yeah
uh so
um my question to you is uh do you feel
the trajectory of trans you know that
there's been any Improvement in
transparency
and perhaps you know maybe comparing
different parts of the intelligence
Community including you know NSA and
then versus CIA or FBI
I think I would make a different point
which is that um
almost without exception
the important things that we learn about
secret government activities come from
leaks and not through oversight
so almost everything important that we
know about government misconduct in the
last two decades was accomplished
because someone on the inside shared
information with the press and the Press
published it now even when things get
Declassified by the government they get
Declassified because of public pressure
following leaks I I really think
breaking the law is the engine
for transparency you know you saw during
the Clinton Administration there was a
kind of
um decent push through a black backlog
of ancient you know classified
information that's kind of not of
interest to me that's not what I'm
talking about I mean interesting things
come out of that and you know the
National Security archive does a good
job there
um and there are you know all kinds of
people thinking about this problem of
the billions of pages of classified
information from the past but in terms
of you know shining a light
on activities at a time that would give
the public an opportunity to engage in
Democratic oversight
very rarely is it a revelation that
comes out in say a public hearing of the
Senate intelligence committee right the
really famous one before Snowden was
Clapper sitting before Ron weiden and
white and saying is there any kind of
information that the NSA collects on
millions or hundreds of millions of
Americans and clappers saying you know
no sir not wittingly
right and you know we all say that was
Clapper lying to Congress but really it
was congress not doing oversight
Congress knew that it was a lie
we were the only ones who didn't know it
was a lie right so so it's episodes like
that that convince someone like Snowden
there's actually not another way
right there isn't a way through the
system through the system is what I just
described to you tediously tonight for
an hour right
thank you
um I'm interested in the role that
international criminal justice might
have to play here and the current
position of the US that well the
objection to
the ICC at all basically
um which is now having ramifications
because
um you know the US won't share
Intelligence on what Putin's doing et
cetera et cetera
um to what extent do you think kind of a
policy change there would
um spill over uh and solve any of these
problems well I I it might but what
possible basis for optimism do we have
here right so I completely understand if
you're in the U.S military right now
um
saying we can't share information with
the ICC because the ICC opened
investigation of the U.S and Afghanistan
right and what did the U.S do in
response we slap sanctions on the ICC
prosecutors and said you can't come to
the United States unless you drop your
investigation of the U.S and Afghanistan
so we can't say
that these tribunals are and
investigatory bodies are illegitimate as
applied to us and then you know but what
a great place for Putin I mean I I do
think that's what they think but it
actually is very difficult and and look
I mean my my thesis here is that
impunity is the organizing principle and
so you know even the need to provide a
little bit more evidence against you
know someone like Putin is not going to
be nearly strong enough incentive for
the U.S to subject its own leaders to
these kinds of tribunals
right
in the back
it's a very brief question and if you'll
answer it tomorrow then then great but I
wonder if you think we would be better
off without all these organizations
which organizations oh are the three
letter agencies the NSA the FBI
I I I I guess I'm not willing to say
that I mean the CIA is probably the
easiest case to say probably
um the the NSA with a properly
constrained role
um
is probably a useful thing to for a
government to have the FBI certainly
with a properly constrained role the FBI
should be doing more to investigate
Financial crime for example
I think having all of these agencies
Focus the way they have on
counterterrorism
and indiscriminately counter-terrorism
so from from the sort of biggest and
most threatening iterations of that to
the smallest and most trivial and even
laughable is a huge huge problem and and
and risks a repetition of what you saw
before the church committee where the
threat was communism the backdrop of
that was nuclear Annihilation but the
day-to-day FBI CIA and NSA files were
left-wing College professors and black
student organizations then that's not
happening now in that same way but I
think having these organizations adopt
counter-terrorism Homeland Security kind
of mandate in this really Broad and
non-specific way
and like using everything as threat fuel
to justify budgets and expansions is a
is a major problem
thank you
are there any other questions
all right so if there are no more
questions I would like to thank everyone
for attending today and I want to remind
you that we're going to continue this
conversation tomorrow at 4 pm same room
the title for tomorrow's talk is the
case against National Security team so I
should warn you that I wrote the title
before I wrote the lecture so it might
have bitten off more than I can choose
I hope you are as hooked as I am and
hold on this talk and I will see you all
tomorrow thank you Ben so much for this
[Applause]
foreign